des policiers débordés des réfugiés
exaspéré avec comme résultat des
affrontements qui ont de nouveau éclaté
sur la petite île grecque de khost en
mer egée qui fait face à un afflux
massif de migrants
ils sont des milliers surtout
originaires de syrie et d'afghanistan à
s'entasser dans un stade dans des
conditions déplorables avec l'espoir
d'obtenir des papiers d'immigration
d'après l'onu sur 224 mille migrants qui
ont fui par la méditerranée depuis
janvier seulement
plus de la moitié soit 124 mille ont
abouti en grèce
beaucoup n'ont même pas eu cette chance
une cinquantaine de migrants sont portés
disparus après un autre naufrage
aujourd'hui en méditerranée seuls
cinquante deux des passagers ont pu être
sauvés
comme cet homme voyez repêché en pleine
mer par un hélicoptère de la marine
italienne avec moi pour en parler
françois o day lé directeur de
l'observatoire canadien sont les crises
et l'aide humanitaire à l'uqam
nous sommes monsieur rudy alors d'abord
évidemment la grèce est un pays on le
sait en pleine crise économique donc un
peu dépassé par ces événements est-ce
que ça risque pas de devenir encore plus
explosif cette situation parce qu'on
voit en grèce
aujourd'hui on le donne en p 12 heures
dans le petit il dit à li na n'est pas
assez et puis jour après jour comme vous
venez de mentionner bien évidemment il
migrants quittent l'afrique du nord le
moyen orient la syrie videmment l'irak
l'afghanistan pour tenter de trouver un
avenir meilleur en europe et évidemment
les premières les premières et pour les
envois être où ils ont une perception ce
sont ces petites îles dans la
méditerranée et ce qui se passe à cause
actuellement est un joli et un petit
échantillon de ce qu'on voit un peu
partout dans les îles de la méditerranée
depuis à peu près deux ans en fait
depuis que kadhafi est tombé en libye ce
qui a fait en sorte de créer une forme
de d'entonnoir où tout n'est l'immigrant
maintenant sont canalisés pour aller
vers l'europe ce qui arrive en grèce ou
en italie en fait c'est le plus chanceux
parce qu en fait y en a encore beaucoup
qui meurent en mer et plus d'un sur deux
en fait ne se rend pas donc les migrants
qui s est traversé la méditerranée
aujourd'hui si on regarde les dernières
données depuis la dernière année
c'est une personne sur deux qui meurent
noyés donc effectivement on pourrait
dire que ceux qui sont arrivés sont
chanceux mais là commence l'aventuré
donc c'est des gens qui sont sans
papiers qui ont tout perdu qui ont
souvent et de la menthe ou laissés de
côté qui doit tout recommencer à zéro et
harry dans une europe et on recentre et
on ressent beaucoup et on voit aussi en
vue dans les médias européens dans une
europe qui s'est pas comment gérer cette
situation là ce soit économique très
difficile en grèce notamment évidemment
qui est pas du tout plu à son actuelle
ment pour recevoir des dizaines de
milliers de personnes supplémentaires
alors qu'elle peine actuellement à
contrôler ses flux financiers pour sa
propre population
mais si ces gens viennent surtout de
l'irak de la syrie de l'afghanistan le
canada que peut-il faire justement il ya
quelques mois en janvier on avait offert
d'accueillir dix mille réfugiés c'est la
promesse du canada on a recueilli on a
accueilli peut-être moins 2000
alors est ce qui aurait pas une façon
pour le canada de faire sa part ben oui
c'est une excellente question et le
canada ne prendront pas fait assez par
rapport à ce qu'il pourrait faire de ne
pas on a besoin de l'immigration chez
nous de toute façon une perspective de
démographie deuxièmement il ya une
population lab en europe qui cherchent
un endroit où s'épanouir leur clairement
juste dimension socio-économique là il
ya clairement un lien est par ailleurs
des six ans de vocation
la dimension humanitaire c'est à dire on
aux mêmes responsabilités
on ne joue un rôle dans ce qui s'est
passé évidemment libye de ce qui se
passe actuellement syrie en irak en
afghanistan le canada est impliqué dans
toutes ces dossiers là alors c'est
certain que on a une responsabilité
maintenant est d'accueillir une partie
de cette population là et seulement
mille fois ci c'est extrêmement long
extrêmement longs les bureaucrates ont
débordé on peut imaginer les enquêtes
qui doivent être faits actuellement pour
tenter faire de retracer les origines
l'identité de l'ensemble de cette
population là on n'est pas dans une
situation serait parfaite où les gens
arrivent je suis pas des états unis ou
de la france avec des bureaucraties où
tout était clair là on a des gens qui
bien des fois on m'aime pas de passeport
ou pas de carte d'identité
alors c'est extrêmement difficile de
s'assurer de la sécurité de ces gens là
mais aussi de savoir qui on reçoit chez
nous et là dessus il ya un délai
extrêmement non malheureusement ce que
le délai est volontaire et on veut
retarder l'arrivée de ces gens là c'est
une question qu'il faudrait portes de
penser aux politiciens mais au fil des
offres reste quelqu'un adore on
n'accueille plus des réfugiés et des
migrants ou moins il ya une baisse nette
depuis les cinq à sept dernières années
dans dans l'ouverture de nos portes face
aux réfugiés
alors qu'une augmentation dans l'aide
qu'on octroie au haut commissariat aux
réfugiés
donc cette organisation là qui va aider
les réfugiés sur le terre alors
autrement dit on semble vouloir
décharger les responsabilités des
réfugiés à travers les nations unies
donc le hr sur le terrain pour
probablement éviter de recevoir des
réfugiés alors c'est une stratégie qui
est un peu qui force la population à
rester chez elle si vous voulez et qui
fait en sorte qu'on reçoit moins de
personnes aujourd'hui qu'il ya dix ans
près pourtant il y a urgence françois
audet merci beaucoup n'ont plus droit